For many of us, having the right sort of social
life has never been too easy.
It’s been hard to find a group of people
who are sensitive, thoughtful, intelligent,
open to introspection and discussion. There’s
a sense that they must be out there somewhere.
But how to find them?
Being the more introverted types, going to
a bar or a club or parties has never felt
too comfortable.
So for too long, we’ve been on our own,
communing with the right sort of person only
in our imaginations, often via books.
And all over the world, compatible sorts of
people have failed to meet one another.
Until now, when the School of Life is ready
to launch a new kind of app expressly designed
to connect introspective, thoughtful types
of people, that is, people interested in intelligent,
and sincere conversation about emotions above
anything else.
We previously built an app, it taught us so
much, but it had limited functionality and
it existed only on Ios. Our new one is in
a whole different league: it’s capable of
live 1-on-1 chat, direct messaging, geolocation
grouping and a whole lot more. Crucially,
it exists on Ios, on Android, and to those
who don’t like apps and just work on desktops
and laptops, on an ordinary web browser too.
We’ve been isolated for too long - needlessly
lonely with our thoughts when potential friends
were so close at hand. We urge you to download
our new app right now - and find the sort
of interesting friends we all long for.
See you online.
If you want to download the new School of
Life app, please click on the link on your
screen now: